Hey everybody, welcome to the podcast.
Today we're gonna talk about AI, artificial intelligence.
We're also gonna talk about the current,
and future state of big tech,
our increasingly automated world,
and the implications of that.
And whether humanity can actually survive
the coming robot apocalypse,
something I say only slightly in jest.
Our steward for this is none other than Kevin Roose.
Kevin is a "New York Times" bestselling author.
He's an award-winning technology columnist
for "The New York Times."
And one of my very favorite people to read,
and follow online for his many insights on everything
from automation to social media, online radicalization,
cybersecurity, and many other tech-related subjects.
If you're a consistent listener, or a viewer of this show
then you already know well my fondness for Kevin's work.
Most notably his podcast "Rabbit Hole"
which is a "New York Times" produced show hosted by Kevin,
and all about what the internet is doing to us.
And I think that this series is a non-negotiable,
must-listen if you haven't already checked it out.
Kevin's latest book,
which consumes a significant portion
of today's conversation is entitled,
"Futureproof: 9 Rules for Humans in the Age of Automation."
It's part AI primer, part self-help survival guide.
It's a great read,
and all about how to be happy, successful humans
in a world increasingly built by and for machines,
but before we dive in, I wanted to very quickly mention
that my latest book "Voicing Change" is now back in stock.
More on this later,
but in the interim to learn more about the book,
and snag your copy, visit richroll.com/vc.
Okay, hit that subscribe button,
please click like if you enjoy the show.
Leave your thoughts in the comments section below,
and let's do this.
This is me and the wonderful Kevin Roose.
Look at that, it's Kevin Roose.
Thanks so much, this is a dream.
Excellent, man.
Well, so delighted to have you here.
I'm such a big fan of all the reporting,
and the work that you've done over the last several years.
You really have become
one of my favorite follows as somebody, myself,
who's obsessed with the implications of big tech
social media platforms,
and the way in which disinformation
infects real-world outcomes,
how you've deconstructed radicalization,
and now, which we're gonna talk a lot about today,
how we should be thinking about AI,
and the coming robot apocalypse.
And the more immersed I become in trying to understand
this rapidly changing environment that we find ourselves in,
I find myself turning more and more to your reporting,
and your insights and your guidance.
So I just wanted to thank you for that at the outset.
Oh, thanks so much.
And I'm a big fan of the show, so this is a thrill for me.
Oh, cool, wow, that's very meaningful, thank you.
And in reflecting over the last year there were three things
that I think impacted me really profoundly.
The first being "The Social Dilemma" Netflix documentary,
the "Feels Good Man" documentary.
I'm wearing the "Feels Good Man" T-shirt.
Did you see that movie?
I haven't seen it yet, no, but should I?
Oh, you have to see it.
I mean, it's just internet to the power of a thousand,
like it's right up your alley.
I think you'd really enjoy it.
And then thirdly,
"Rabbit Hole" which I've discussed at length many times
on the podcast often with my sometime co-host,
Adam Skolnick, who's also a "New York Times" contributor.
I love that series.
I think it's a must-listen for everybody.
I wish that there was a new episode every week.
So before we get into futureproof, and all of that,
can we spend a few minutes talking about "Rabbit Hole?"
Yeah, absolutely, whatever you want.
So for people that aren't familiar,
maybe it would be worth just providing
a little bit of a synopsis.
Sure, so "Rabbit Hole" is an eight part podcast
that I helped produce and host with "The New York Times"
about basically the idea was to do a podcast
exploring sort of what the internet is doing to us.
So I'm a tech columnist, I report on the internet,
and for a long time that meant reporting on gadgets,
and companies that made gadgets,
and software programs and new apps,
and social media platforms.
And then a couple of years ago it really started to shift
because what we saw is that a lot of the things
that were happening in the offline world
had sort of online antecedents,
had like things that were happening on the internet
that led directly to things that happened
in the offline world,
and the most jarring and horrible example of that
was the shooting in Christchurch, New Zealand.
And if people remember that was the really deadly one.
I think 52 people ended up dying,
and the shooter was a white nationalist
who radicalized online,
and who was very obviously spending a lot of time online,
and he live-streamed this shooting,
and posted about it on the internet.
And it was sort of like this internet event
that was kind of engineered for virality.
And it really like, I don't report on terrorism.
I don't cover mass shootings,
but this was such like an internet event.
And so deeply tied to the kinds of extremism,
and sort of violent rhetoric I'd seen
on places like 4chan and 8chan
that I just decided I had to look into that.
And I had to figure out, like my question was basically,
I mean, I grew up on the internet.
I'm like a child of the internet,
and I love technology and the internet.
And, also, I was seeing how it was radicalizing people,
and turning them into extremists.
And so I wanted to figure out how that happened.
Like what is it actually doing to us?
How do the systems and the algorithms interact
with our information ecosystem?
Who are the people who are sort of doing the radicalizing?
Like what is this whole ecosystem,
and how is it affecting who we are?
So that's what we spent a year digging into
starting with this guy, Caleb Cain,
who was a 26-year-old kid from West Virginia,
who got really into YouTube videos,
and he became radicalized,
and he was able to dig up and send us
years worth of his YouTube browsing history.
So we actually got to go back and kind of reconstruct
how this guy who had supported Obama,
and cared about the environment,
and loved Michael Moore movies,
morphed into this guy who was, like, deep in the kind of
alt-right fever swamp,
and actually trace his path sort of down the rabbit hole.
And what was the decision to do it as a podcast,
as opposed to a long read,
or a series of articles over a period of time?
Well, some of it did appear in articles,
but it's really like, it's just different to hear it.
I mean you know this from doing podcasts,
like so much is conveyed in the voice,
and so much is conveyed in hearing things
rather than reading them and so,
especially, with this series,
which was all about sort of internet media,
and the charismatic people on YouTube
who are radicalizing young white men,
like, it's just much more compelling
to hear those people talk
than to read transcriptions of what they're saying.
And, ultimately, like, we had an amazing team of people
putting this together and they sort of came up with the idea
of making the whole show sort of sound like the experience
of falling into an internet rabbit hole.
Right.
So if you pay attention, it's sort of like,
it's kind of engineered in this really sort of careful,
and thoughtful, and cool way
where there are no, like, intros and outros of the episodes.
It just goes, like, straight into one episode from another.
And it sort of, like, mimics the feeling
of falling into an internet rabbit hole.
I'm sure everyone's done this,
you start watching one YouTube video,
and then four hours later you're like,
why am I watching, like, videos of trains in Norway?
Right, right, right.
Like, how did I get here?
And that's sort of the feeling
that we wanted to recreate in the show.
Yeah, well, you were very successful in that regard.
I mean, it is truly a sonic experience,
and it was fascinating
to go on this archeological exploration
of how this young man step-by-step
finds his way from one place to a very different place,
which then, of course,
brings up the subject of the algorithm,
the nature of the algorithm,
and how this is being managed by YouTube.
You have a couple interviews with Susan Wojcicki at YouTube.
And I guess my question is
so much has happened since "Rabbit Hole."
What is your sense of what that algorithm looks like now,
or the job that YouTube is doing
to protect against these sorts of
acts of violence in the future?
Well, I think YouTube
is doing a better job than they were.
I mean, when we started reporting this series
they were still sort of saying there wasn't a problem,
that they didn't have extremists on their service.
It was they were kind of just like bizarrely uninterested
in dealing with what I saw, and a lot of people saw
as sort of this growing threat of radicalization
that was happening on YouTube primarily,
and not just on YouTube,
but through YouTube's recommendation algorithm,
which is responsible for something like 70%
of all the time people spend on YouTube
is due to that little sidebar,
that's powered by some of the most sophisticated AI
that's ever been created.
And so that's the piece that we wanted to sort of connect
was how is the algorithm sort of pulling people into,
it's not just the people are falling into rabbit holes,
it's that they're sort of being pulled,
and what is that force, and how has that evolved over time?
And so I think they've made a lot of changes
since the series came out.
They've updated their policies on hate speech,
and white nationalism.
They're kicking neo-Nazis off.
Some of the worst people in that world
have been sort of de-platformed,
and they've changed their recommendation algorithm now.
They call it borderline content, like stuff that basically
doesn't violate their rules technically,
but is like not great.
And they're showing something like 70% fewer recommendations
for that kind of content through this algorithm now.
So I think there's still obviously more to do.
There's still a ton of extremism on every internet platform,
and, YouTube, I think has a ways to go in that regard,
but I think they're at least aware of the problem now
in a way that they maybe weren't when we started reporting.
Yeah, and in fairness, and you pose this question, too.
His name is name is Caleb, right?
The young man.
Yep.
The very same algorithm that prompted him
to descend down this rabbit hole is the algorithm
that also ultimately introduces him to other ideas,
and helps him start to critically think about
his long-held beliefs and ultimately change them.
So the argument could be made that the algorithm ultimately
served a positive purpose,
or worked in a way that is counterintuitive
to the less nuanced narrative
that it just pushes people in one direction only.
For sure, I mean, this algorithm,
the thing is it has no idea what it's recommended, right?
It is just a machine.
And it is looking at these, like, blank boxes,
and it's saying, okay, when people watch box A
they spend 10% more time on YouTube than box B.
So let's show them box A.
Like it has no idea what's in box A,
so it is not like anyone at YouTube
is fiddling with the dials and saying,
okay, we want to show them more right-wing content,
or more left-wing content.
It's just not, that's not how it works.
So for Caleb what was really interesting is, yeah,
he did get pulled out of this far right rabbit hole
that he was in because he stumbled into this part of YouTube
called BreadTube,
which is this sort of left-wing, like, hyper-ironic,
very online community of YouTubers,
who are basically just sort of
combating right-wing radicalization
by kind of mimicking the aesthetics
of how right-wing radicalization works on YouTube, so.
You know all the videos that are like,
Ben Shapiro destroys, like, helpless college student.
It's sort of like that combative thing.
And so they were making videos that were like
college student destroys Ben Shapiro,
sort of taking all the lessons that they learned,
and trying to kind of hijack the algorithm in this way
where their videos would show up to people
who were looking for this other stuff.
So in some ways, it's not that the algorithm
sort of pushed him to the left.
It's the creators who are the other piece of this equation
had kind of formed this strategy around the algorithm
in an attempt to get into the recommendations of people
like Caleb and bring them out of the far right.
Right, getting more savvy about how YouTube works
to marshal that engine, and weaponize it in a direction
counter to the narrative that they're trying to confront.
Exactly, yeah.
And that's, I think, like. what drew me to this topic
in the first place is, like, I started feeling
like the entire world was kind of arranging itself
around these algorithms.
Like all the political figures who were succeeding
were like doing it by, like, hacking the Facebook algorithm,
or the Twitter algorithm,
like posting became this, like, very valuable skill
in our politics, and in our culture.
The celebrities who were figuring out how to use TikTok,
and YouTube to sort of get themselves out there,
like they were becoming the most famous people in the world.
And it just felt like the world that we see is
so formed, and shaped by the decisions that a few engineers,
and a few CEOs are making
in ways that I don't think we fully understand yet,
but that are appearing in all of our lives everyday.
Yeah, and it should be said
that this is not simply endemic to YouTube.
One of the things
that you've done over the past year is share
the top 10 most shared posts on Facebook everyday.
And they tend to be overwhelmingly of the right-wing.
And so that begs the question is this because
this is where the country's at, and this is what they want,
or is it that this particular strain of politics
is just better at understanding how Facebook works
to get their stuff to travel virally.
Yeah, I think it's really hard to untangle those things
because one thing that we know is that these algorithms,
these recommendation engines,
they don't just recommend things to us.
They can change our minds.
There's a French researcher named Camille Roth,
he distinguishes between read your mind algorithms,
and change your mind algorithms.
And we think that a lot of the stuff we're dealing with
on an everyday basis is reading our minds.
Like I like this Netflix show,
so I'm also gonna like this Netflix show,
but in reality, like, Netflix can corrupt that process
by saying, like, we want you to watch this thing
instead of this other thing.
And so they're actually steering,
setting up our choices in such a way that we actually don't.
We're not the ones sort of making the call
even if it feels like we are.
Right.
And so that process is really interesting,
and I think really troubling.
Right, and that's a central tenet of futureproof, right?
We tend to think about automation
in the context of the robot apocalypse,
but in reality it's these tectonic plates
that are shifting under our feet currently
that we're really not even consciously aware of.
I mean, you make the point in the book about
buying a pair of shoes,
and did I really even want these shoes,
or did I just think because it was in front of me
that they were cool?
Like we have divested our decision-making power,
and a certain aspect of critical thinking to algorithms
that are making these decisions for us,
and deluding ourselves that we're actually,
that we have agency over that
when, in fact, that's less true than it's ever been.
Yeah, I mean, recommendations are so powerful
to a degree that I didn't fully appreciate
until I started looking into this book,
and talking to the engineers
who actually program recommendations algorithms.
There's been some great studies that basically show
that we trust what algorithms recommend for us
more than we trust own tastes.
If you show us, if you give us a food that we hate,
or a song that we hate,
and then you tell us
this was algorithmically selected for you
based on your preexisting tastes we actually like it.
Like we let the machines override our own preferences.
I think you're exactly right,
that we think of automation as this kind of
external force in the world,
but there's a kind of internalized automation
that I think is something
that we're just starting to deal with.
And I think that's part of what people are sort of
trying to unpack is like
what do I actually think and believe, and like, and enjoy,
and, like, what is being put there by some machine?
Right, everyday you open up your phone,
something has occurred in the news cycle.
And before you can take a minute
to read a neutral article about it you go to Twitter,
and you just see what everyone's hot take is on it.
And then you're, like, well, I like that guy.
So I guess I agree with that person's perspective on this,
and less and less we're left to our own interior spaces
to figure out how that perspective
aligns with our core values.
Like we really have just outsourced so much of this,
and it happens so incrementally
that we're not aware of it, like I said earlier,
and we all think that we're not susceptible to it
like other people are, but I'm good.
Yeah.
There's a researcher named Oscar Gandy,
who has this sort of theory about
the difference between identity and identification.
So identity is what we have.
That's what we develop during childhood.
It's what we work on when we work on ourselves.
It's who I am, what kinds of things I like,
what I value, what my relationships are like,
how I want to show up in the world,
like those sort of basic human questions.
And then there's identification,
which is kind of the categories we belong to,
the tribes that we associate with,
the kind of the sort of consumer segments we are a part of.
And that's what is being used by the tech companies,
in the platforms to sell us stuff, to shift our views,
to change us into a version of ourselves
that is more predictable,
and clear-cut than we might actually be,
and that has an affect.
And when identification becomes identity
like that is really bad.
Like that means we have lost the plot,
and we are no longer in charge of our own lives.
Right, we'll be back in a sec, but first,
if you enjoy this podcast, and I hope you're enjoying it,
then something tells me
I think you'll really dig my latest book, "Voicing Change"
featuring excerpts from, poignant essays by,
and glorious photography of some 50 of my favorite guests
over the last eight plus years of doing this thing,
this podcast.
It's a gorgeous artful compendium of the show,
and copious wisdom shared therein,
all wrapped in a hardcover coffee table form
that provides a great taste of what we do here at the RRP,
and also serves as a beautiful keepsake,
or gift, or primer for the ardent fan.
The book is only and exclusively available on our website.
Signed copies are available,
and we're shipping globally direct
to any coffee table on planet Earth.
So to learn more and snag your copy today,
visit richroll.com/vc, that's richroll.com/vc.
All right, let's get back into it.
Back to the algorithm subject for a second.
You, in addition to these conversations
that you have with Susan,
you introduce PewDiePie into the equation,
and kind of show the history of this guy's ascent
to becoming the emperor of the internet.
And it's really the story of a young man
grappling with the responsibilities
of so many millions of people
paying attention to what he says,
and making mistakes in real time,
and trying to understand where he's gone awry,
and where that responsibility rests.
And there's a parallel with Susan in that,
she being, like, the 16th employee at Google
from the very beginning
when YouTube was just cat videos, et cetera,
and then inheriting a responsibility
that nobody could have predicted,
and grappling with the very real world problems
of how to police is the wrong word,
but manage that responsibility.
And it just seems like an almost impossible task
for a team of people to manage,
whether with some aspect of automation, or not.
And I just don't know
with more and more people uploading everyday,
and the billions of hours that are on there,
how that can be accomplished.
And, of course, from an ethical perspective
how much of that should be managed or policed?
Yeah, there's a lot in what you just said.
And I think that you're right to sort of point out
that the task that these companies have set for themselves
is really an impossible one.
I mean, to responsibly curate billions of hours of video
everyday is probably impossible.
And you can get better or worse at doing it,
but you're never gonna be perfect.
And I think that the thing about algorithms
is that they have goals, right?
You have an algorithm,
and you are trying to use that algorithm
to maximize some variable.
And with YouTube that variable has actually changed
over the years.
So at first it was
we're trying to maximize the number of clicks.
Like we want people to click on videos.
And so they implemented this algorithm,
and it worked for a while.
And then people started to game it
with these, like, clickbait titles,
and they would have these sensational thumbnails,
and then you'd open a video,
and it would be a guy scratching his armpits for 45 minutes.
It didn't have anything to do with what the title was.
And so then they changed the variable to watch time.
And they said, we want people to watch YouTube
for as long as possible.
And so the algorithm was trained,
and calibrated to produce watch time, and that worked.
Like it was a really good algorithm producing watch time.
Unfortunately, one of the ways
that it produced a lot of watch time
was by steering people into these extremist communities.
And so that is a side effect
that I don't think they anticipated.
I talked to one guy who was a former YouTube engineer,
Guillaume Chaslot,
who was part of the team that developed the AI.
And he sort of brought up some of these concerns.
He said, I think we're only showing people
one side of the story.
We're feeding them conspiracy theories.
And he was kind of ignored and eventually got pushed out.
And so I think the goals that we give our algorithms
are so, so important,
and it doesn't have to be watch time.
It doesn't have to be clicks.
It doesn't have to be outrage.
It doesn't have to be engagement.
It could be something else.
And I think the tech companies need to adjust
what they're aiming for.
And I think good things could come of that.
Hmm, so that's an optimistic bent.
I'm mostly optimistic. I mean, I know I write about
horrible things happening on the internet,
but, actually, like, this surprises people
because my, like, Twitter feed is all, like, QAnon,
and like extremists and neo-Nazis.
And like I deal in like a lot of like really gross stuff
happening on the internet,
but I am actually, like, I'm optimistic about people.
I'm not optimistic about, like, all people,
but I'm optimistic about
that if you give people good information
they will make better choices.
And I think that one thing
that we sort of often don't realize
is that algorithms are just people.
I mean, algorithms are not some magical detached thing.
They're built by humans who give them goals,
who tell them what to maximize,
who calibrate them, and train the models.
Cathy O'Neil, who's a great writer on the subject
says that algorithms are opinions embedded in code.
And I think when we start to realize that these algorithms
aren't some iron law of the universe,
that they can be changed and adjusted,
it becomes a lot more hopeful
because you start to realize, like, how it is right now
isn't how it has to be.
Sure, but at the same time,
there is a fundamental misalignment of incentives
across all of these big
social media platforms
in that when they're oriented around maximizing watch time,
or keeping you on the platform,
it's generally for the purpose of serving you up
as many ads as possible
so that they can ratchet up their ad revenue,
and until or unless there is a new sort of
conceptual orientation around what a social media platform
can and should be
where the incentives are set up in a healthier dynamic,
we're gonna continue to see the kind of bad actors,
and gaming of the system that we've seen today.
Totally, and that's why I think we need new incentives
for these networks,
and for the networks that are going to replace them.
I mean, every social network
gets replaced eventually, right?
It's sort of one of the parts of,
one of the most predictable things in the tech world
is that every company dies and is replaced.
Every MySpace has a Facebook.
Every Friendster has a MySpace.
And so I think what we're trying to figure out right now
is like what's gonna come after
our current social platforms,
and how will they be different?
And my hope is that seeing how the last generation
sort of screwed things up,
and how long it took them to fix their problems
will instruct the people building the next generation,
and maybe they'll still make mistakes.
And this is still very much a work in progress.
And I think some of this is just sort of us evolving,
or adapting to our new environment technologically,
but I'm hopeful when I see people
making more thoughtful decisions at these companies,
not that necessarily those companies will become nonprofits,
and give back all the money that they made
from promoting extremism, or whatever,
but just that people are at least aware
that these pitfalls are out there.
Yeah, sure, I mean, I suppose the current test case
in the Petri dish right now is Clubhouse,
and this is something you've reported on,
and made a very keen observation,
which is that all of the things that we traditionally see
in the arc of a social media platform
are all kind of happening simultaneously with Clubhouse.
Like it starts out like this utopian place
where everybody's sharing ideas and it's wonderful,
and then enter the bad actors, and then, okay,
so what are the community guidelines gonna be?
And then how are we gonna monetize that?
But this is all occurring with a very compressed timeline,
which I think is interesting in that it elucidates,
like how fast everything is moving now,
like the fact that this life cycle
is occurring instantaneously
when with Facebook it took years and years and years
for this kind of dialogue and progression to unfold.
Totally, this is all happening so fast.
And, like, Clubhouse isn't even technically released yet.
I know, it's still like in beta.
It's still in beta, right?
But it's already been through like the first 10 years
of Facebook's problems.
And it's now sort of trying to figure out,
like, where to draw the lines,
but I think Clubhouse is really instructive to me because,
I don't know how much time you spend on there,
but I spend a fair bit of time on there.
And it seems to me like therapy for people who have been,
like, traumatized by other social media platforms.
It's like group therapy where you're like,
okay, what did we just do to ourselves
for the last 10 years?
Like I was in a room the other day,
and the topic was sort of like,
why we hate our Twitter personas.
Like a lot of people I think have spent years
crafting these personas that aren't even really them,
and that they sort of grow to hate
because everything has to be a little sharper
for the retweets.
And like you've got to, like, throw throw the jabs in there,
and, like, start fights.
And, like, maybe you're saying things
that you don't even really mean.
And you look at them later,
and you're like, why did I do that?
And I think people are starting to really,
there's like this growing feeling of like,
I don't like who I show up as on the internet,
on social media.
And so Clubhouse to me feels like a response to that piece
of where we all are right now.
Yeah, that's cool.
I mean, I've been a bit of a lurker there.
I have yet to chime in on anything.
I'm gonna host my first Clubhouse chat
in another week or two,
but I've just been trying to sort of listen in
like yourself, and figure out what's going on.
And it does seem to me fundamentally different.
There is something about the participatory aspect of it.
It's like being on a conference call
with a whole bunch of people
where everybody gets to say the fact that it's not recorded.
And then it disappears afterwards feels like it sort of,
it's like a pressure valve release on that idea
that everything I say has to be finely honed,
and directly on point.
And it seems to be supportive in general.
Like everybody conducts themselves
respectfully of each other.
Maybe there's rooms where that's not occurring,
but that's been my experience to date.
Yeah, I mean, to me it feels more human.
It feels like we are more complicated people on Clubhouse
than we are on Twitter
where we're all sort of flattened down into these like,
two-dimensional avatars
that just, like, fight with each other all the time.
I've had people who like,
call me the worst names possible on Twitter,
and then they show up in a Clubhouse room,
and they're perfectly pleasant and cordial.
And it's like, what happened to that person?
Like, yeah, like where did that guy go,
and why is he not calling me a communist?
It feels like and I don't know,
I mean, Clubhouse has problems,
like there's tons of harassment and hate speeches.
It's got all the problems
that any big social network would have,
but I do think we're starting to see new models emerging
that maybe allow people to be a little bit more human.
I mean, having a conversation voice to voice
is so much different than having it avatar to avatar.
And I think it's better and think it's more humane,
and I think it leads to better places.
And so I think that's what the next generation
of tech platforms are gonna be built around
is, like, how do we show up as ourselves on the internet,
and get away from these kind of
two-dimensional caricatures we've created?
Sure, what's your sense of how it will impact podcasting?
I don't think it's the same thing.
I mean, there's some overlap,
especially the kind of, like, more produced Clubhouse rooms
where you have hosts and guests, and some parts
there's sort of like a little Venn diagram middle there,
but it's so different,
and podcasts are wonderful
because you can really go deep on a subject.
Clubhouse, I found is sort of more like,
it's like more like going to a bar, and you're talking,
and one minute you're talking about video games,
and the next minute you're talking about crypto,
and it's just sort of this sort of moving conversation
that is kind of fun to be part of.
My big thing about Clubhouse is I don't know
whether it's gonna outlast the pandemic.
I think that when people can go outside again,
and talk to their friends and go to bars,
like, I can't see myself spending
three hours a night on my phone
listening to some guy talk about NFTs for artists.
Well, I think there will be some breakout Clubhouse stars,
and those are gonna be the people
who are showing up consistently to host
a very kind of curated experience.
So it's gonna be less about the meandering nonsense,
and I think more targeted.
And with that you'll see monetization
whether it's subscriptions, or ad supported shows.
So I think it will not only survive but thrive,
but I think the early entries
where it's just a bunch of people talking about nothing,
I do agree, I think that people will tire of that.
I mean, that was a lot of podcasts, too,
in the early days, right?
It's a lot of podcasts now.
It's just, like, people talking about nothing.
It still is, there are like two million podcasts,
so there's plenty of that.
Right, so I think as platforms mature,
like the bar kind of gets higher,
like you need to show up
with a little bit more fire to, like, make a dent,
but I think right now,
Clubhouse is still in the weird experimental phase,
which I love.
Like I have no interest in, like, the boring,
like, business Clubhouse rooms.
I love the weirdos.
Like there's this group the other day
it was called, like, Whale Moan.
And it was all people just moaning like whales
in a Clubhouse room.
Uh-huh.
There's like this group called the Cotton Club
where, like, you go in and you change your avatar
to a black and white photo,
and you pretend like you're in the 1920s.
And someone says, like, hey, Rich,
like, what are you having tonight?
What are you drinking?
And there's jazz playing,
It's like sort of a fun, like, virtual world.
So I love the weirdos
who are experimenting with stuff on there.
Yeah, cool, all right, well, one more thing about
"Rabbit Hole" before we move on.
The last two episodes focus on QAnon.
And for a lot of people, I have to believe that
that perhaps may have been their introduction
to the world of QAnon.
And at that time when the podcast was first released,
it, of course, metastasized into this whole thing.
You have written about your perspective
on the current state of QAnon,
but because so much occurred in the aftermath
of completing "Rabbit Hole"
I do think it would be good to hear a little bit about
your perspective on QAnon now,
and also whether there is a plan to do a season two,
like there's still so much to be mined here.
Like I would love for you guys to continue this project.
Yeah, well, I'll talk about the QAnon piece of it first.
I mean, what drew me to QAnon.
I started off in journalism as a religion reporter.
I spent a semester undercover at Liberty University,
Jerry Falwell's super right-wing Christian university.
And I came from, like, a very secular home,
very liberal, secular,
and so I was just, like, fascinated
by the existence of these like right-wing evangelicals.
So I went there for a semester,
took all the classes, sang in their church choir,
lived in the dorms.
I wrote a book about that,
and that was sort of my introduction into journalism.
And when I started hearing about QAnon
a couple of years ago, it really triggered the, like,
oh, this is a religion thing for me.
It was, like, there are all these people,
they believe in this, like, narrative about
how the world operates, and whose pulling the strings,
and, like, these powers beyond our comprehension.
And they're following this mystical character on 4chan,
who's dropping little clues
that they're all sort of interpreting together,
and it's filling that sort of community need
in a lot of their lives.
People think QAnon is just like a bunch of wackos,
like, being insane on the internet.
And there is some of that,
but people are also using this as
it's become people's social lives.
They're making friends.
It's an activity that they do together on the internet.
It's a lot of fun for them.
And so I felt a real parallel between that,
and sort of the religious reporting
that I had done earlier in my career.
And so I just decided, like, I got to investigate this.
So I spent a long time talking to QAnon believers,
hanging out in chat rooms listening to their conversations,
reading up on the movement.
And we did these two episodes about QAnon.
And then after that, like, at the time QAnon
was sort of like this novelty thing.
It was like, oh, look at these interesting weirdos.
Like they may be a little violent sometimes
around the edges, but like mostly,
it's just strange and troubling,
but, like, maybe not an immediate threat.
And then they marched on the Capitol, right?
Right.
And it was, like, the QAnon riot at the Capitol.
And QAnon was a big part of the Stop the Steal thing.
And suddenly it was, like,
oh, this is not just like a cult of internet weirdos.
This is like an extremist political movement
that is like creating real offline violence and harms.
So yeah, I mean, I think there's so much more there.
I'm still fascinated by QAnon.
I think the movement is kind of dissipating
because Trump isn't the president anymore,
which was the whole fun of it
was that Trump was the president.
And so now I think a lot of their predictions
have not come true.
There are no mass arrests
of satanic pedophiles in government.
And so I think a lot of people have sort of
quietly moved on.
And as far as season two,
you should talk to my my bosses at "The New York Times,"
but it's really, like, I think it would shock you
how hard it is to make something like that.
Oh, you don't have to tell me.
Like.
I mean, I can't imagine, like I have such an appreciation
for the production quality of what you guys created.
I mean, that is a Herculean effort to pull that together,
and to kind of create the experience that you created.
I know how much work it is just for me
to do simple conversations with people.
To do what you do is an entirely different thing.
Like I understand that requires a tremendous amount of time,
and resources and money, et cetera,
but it's tremendously valuable.
Thank you, yeah.
I'm happy to call your bosses.
Yeah, please do.
I mean, I was shocked by that, too,
'cause I come from the world of like writing,
which is like time-consuming,
and requires a lot of thoughtfulness,
but I think podcasting that kind of podcasting,
the kind of hyper produced narrative podcast
is actually more like making a film
than writing a newspaper article.
And I didn't appreciate that.
Like you gather hundreds of hours of tape,
and then you cut it down into 36 minutes.
And it's like all this work,
and then you're, like, that's it, eight episodes?
Right, 27 minutes, yeah.
Right, right, but I think it's,
I mean, it was a ton of fun, very rewarding.
I love podcasts as a medium,
and I hope I can keep doing them.
So yeah, if want to call up my bosses over that,
I would not turn you down.
Cool, well, let's talk about the new book.
First of all, it's pub day for you, so congrats on that.
That's very exciting.
Thank you.
It's not that much of a leap
given where your focus has been talking about algorithms,
which is by its very nature a discussion around automation
to the broader conversation around AI,
and what the future and the present looks like
in terms of our personal lives, our careers,
and what our communities look like.
And what I appreciate about the book
is that you approached it,
well, first of all it's like part primer on what AI is,
and what the nature of automation truly looks like,
but then it's also this sort of a prescriptive manual
on how to deal with all of this.
It's like, it is in many ways a self-help book,
which is very cool, but it's laced with nuance.
It's neither utopian nor dystopian.
Like you're really trying to grapple with all of this
in the most objective way.
So maybe we could start with just what prompted you
to want to write a book about this?
Like what was the question lingering in your mind
that led to this work?
Well, it was literally a self-help book.
I mean, I was mostly asking,
like, is this gonna happen to me?
Like am I gonna lose my job to some algorithm?
Am I turning into a zombie who just,
like, scrolls through his feeds all day,
and then goes to bed and wakes up and does it again,
like, I was really worried about what I was becoming
as a result of these algorithms, and this automation,
and this AI and what my future was gonna look like, so.
I go to a lot of tech events for work,
and I talk to a lot of people in the industry.
This was a few years ago,
and I was really sort of shocked by how simplistic,
and sort of theoretical the conversation around AI,
and automation was.
There were people who said all of this is terrible.
Robots are gonna take all the jobs.
We're gonna be unemployed,
and homeless, and it's gonna be awful.
We're gonna be the people in "Wall-E"
driving around on our chairs drinking Big Gulps.
And there are other people who think
this is gonna be amazing,
and AI is gonna help us discover new cancer drugs,
and fix the climate crisis.
And those were sort of binary opinions,
but there wasn't a lot in the middle.
And there also wasn't much that felt practical.
Like what do I actually do if I am working in a job
that is likely to be automated?
How do I know if I'm in the risk zone?
And if I am like what can I do?
Do I go back to school?
Do I learn to code?
Like, do I start sucking up to Alexa
so that when the robot revolution comes
I end up on the robot's side,
like what is the actual action item here?
And so I couldn't find that,
like, I kept just trying to find,
like, anything that would help me deal with this problem,
and it didn't exist.
And so I decided to write it.
So the first half of the book is the kind of diagnosis part.
That's like what is actually happening with AI,
and automation, how is it changing the world around us?
It's not about the future it's about the present,
and the ways that these things are showing up in our lives,
and what it's doing to us.
And then the second half, as you said,
is the more prescriptive part where I'm telling people,
like, here are nine things you can do
to futureproof your life, your career, and your community.
So let's talk a little bit about
what's happening in the present,
because I think it sort of belies this conventional notion
that AI or automation is all about,
robots on the factory floor.
And that's certainly the case,
but that's almost like the past,
like that's been accomplished.
And there is a lot of AI happening right now,
right underneath our feet that we're unaware of,
but has real kind of existential implications
in terms of the workforce not just with blue collar workers,
but now very much white collar workers.
Yeah, I think we still have this outdated notion
that automation is something that happens to people
in car factories, and that it comes in.
You come into work one day, and there's a machine there,
and sorry, Rich, your job has been automated.
Have fun finding new work.
That's not really how it works anymore most of the time.
And that's not who it happens to most of the time.
Most people who are being displaced by AI and automation
are not manufacturing workers.
They're people in retail.
They're people doing clerical work,
and they're increasingly white collar professionals,
like, doing the kinds of things that you and I do.
People in sales, people in finance, people in medicine,
people in law.
There are now algorithms
that can diagnose certain types of cancers more accurately
than human radiologists.
So it's not just like truck drivers,
and McDonald's cashiers and factory workers.
And so I think that requires us to sort of
update our mental model of what this stuff is,
and how it's going to affect our lives
because for a long time this was sort of like
people like me thought this is someone else's problem.
Uh mm, uh mm, and with that,
from my perspective,
it's almost that nobody is immune, right?
Like, you talk about how one of the kind of catalysts
for this was understanding
early in your career when you were a financial reporter,
that a lot of those articles are now generated by AI.
There isn't even a journalist
that writes these financial report documents.
So if that could be the case then is anybody safe?
And was it last week where there was the whole
Tom Cruise deepfake thing on TikTok.
Like even Tom Cruise is not immune
from being automated into movies.
So it is frightening.
And it does beg the question of, like,
what are we gonna do about this?
But at the same time kind of balancing out against that,
you also see these AI generated screenplays
that are terrible,
or the point of sale machine at the grocery store
that never works right.
Like a lot of this stuff is super janky.
Like, it feels like it's super futuristic,
and, also, completely ineffectual at the same time.
Yeah, there's a great concept
that I got from these two economists,
Daron Acemoglu, and Pascual Restrepo,
who write about automation and its affects on labor markets.
And they talk about this concept of so-so automation,
which is sort of the janky automation you're talking about.
It's like the grocery store self-checkout thing,
or like the call center,
you call for customer service
when you need to like renew your insurance, or something.
And like, it's the kind of automation
that actually isn't much better if it's at all better
than the humans it replaced but it is cheaper.
And it allows companies to reduce their costs,
but it doesn't, like, make them, I mean,
in the past what's happened is we've gotten technology
that displaces some old jobs,
but it also creates new jobs, right?
The car, the automobile displaced a lot of carriage drivers,
and people who sold buggy whips,
and blacksmiths who made horseshoes,
but suddenly you could get a job as a chauffeur,
or a car dealer, or a mechanic.
And so that's kind of the way
that we've been able to kind of keep the economy running,
even as people get displaced,
but these new kinds of automation
that we're seeing a lot more of,
these kind of so-so forms of automation
they're basically just good enough to replace humans,
but not good enough to enable other kinds of work,
and to grow productivity, and to grow the economy.
And so the solution is actually not less automation,
it's better automation.
Right, you talk about the productivity paradox.
Like if these innovations in AI were so good
then how come we're not infinitely more productive
than we were before?
We're kind of the same.
And what's qualitatively different about this moment is that
the AI that we're onboarding at the moment
isn't having that reciprocal impact on creating new jobs.
It's eliminating jobs,
but we're not seeing the opportunities
that generally come with new innovations,
and that's kind of
the hearkening of something very different.
Totally, yeah, there's the whole industry
that's grown up in the last 10 years,
and it's called RPA, it's robotic process automation.
And this is basically companies that sell software
to replace humans in the workplace.
So they're companies you've never heard of,
like UiPath, and Automation Anywhere, and Blue Prism.
They're kind of these faceless like B2B software companies,
but they're huge, and they're making tons of money.
And the way that they're doing that is by selling Coca-Cola,
or Walgreens a software package,
and saying we can do with one bot,
what used to take 20 people in billing to do.
And so executives love this stuff 'cause it's cheap,
and it's easy, and it's efficient.
And even if it's not quite as good as the humans
who used to do that job,
even if it makes some mistakes,
and you have to kind of come in and correct it,
you're still lowering your costs.
And so that's what they're going after.
And that industry, I think, flies under their people's radar
'cause it's not flashy.
It's not Siri and Alexa, it's not flying cars.
It's not self-driving Ubers.
It's this very basic office automation software,
but it's had a huge impact on the labor market.
Right, and, of course,
the pandemic has presented the opportune moment
to implement a lot of these automated systems,
while everybody's working from home,
and to do it in kind of a guiltless manner.
So talk a little bit about how COVID
has accelerated this process.
Well, COVID has really transformed
the way that executives feel about automation.
That has been the biggest thing.
I mean, there are certainly companies
that have used automation to kind of get through COVID.
So meat packing plants, FedEx, shipping companies,
they've had to sort of bring in robotics and automation
just to be able to kind of keep up with demand
while some of their humans are out sick,
but there's this other piece of this which is that
I think for a long time executives knew
that they could automate people,
but they were hesitant to do it
because they didn't want to be seen as job killers.
They saw what happened to executives in the '90s
who sent jobs, who outsourced jobs to India and China,
they became villains,
and they were sort of the bad guys in global capitalism.
And so I think a lot of them sort of hesitated.
They said, well, let's try to do a little bit of automation,
but like maybe not the kind
that's gonna replace anyone, and we'll sort of play it safe.
And then COVID happened.
And it was like someone described it to me,
a consultant who helps companies
sort of do this kind of automation said, it's basically,
the executives are saying like we don't care anymore.
Like we just need to do what we need to do for our business.
And he said, it's made automation
a lot more politically acceptable
because tons of people are out of work.
Businesses are shutting down.
And so people, I think, are a lot more
sort of forgiving of companies
that need to make these changes right now.
So the flood gates have kind of been opened in a way.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Before we get into the prescriptive aspect of all of this
was there anything that surprised you in all the research
that you've done?
I mean, obviously you're very tech fluent,
and savvy going into this,
but what was something
that you didn't expect that you learned?
Well, I had sort of bought this narrative
that I had heard from people in Silicon Valley,
which is that basically every time
there's like a big tech transformation,
whether it's the first Industrial Revolution,
or the invention of electricity,
or the kind of factory automation of the 1960s and '70s,
that this has gone pretty smoothly.
Like that's the sort of story
that people tell out here in the Bay Area is, like,
yeah, there were some farmers
who had to learn how to work in factories,
but like, overall, this improved everyone's lives.
People were happy
that they no longer had to do the old jobs.
And so I went back,
and I actually read a lot of the primary sources,
like people's journals from the Industrial Revolution,
things like that.
And, like, it sucked for a lot of people.
Like, this was not a happy time in a lot of worker's lives
because all of a sudden,
they had to learn new skills, go to a new place to work,
deal with these, like, awful working conditions.
There's child labor,
there's exploitation on a massive scale.
And worker's wages actually didn't reflect
the increased productivity.
Corporate owners and factory owners
were making a ton more money because of all the automation,
but workers weren't actually seeing a lot of that.
And this happened, again, with electricity,
and again with factory automation in the 1960s and '70s.
There's a great book by this economist named Carl Frey,
called "The Technology Trap"
and it's all about how we've kind of invented this history
where technology just comes in,
and there's a little bit of displacement.
It's a little rocky for a few years,
but then everyone moves on and we're prosperous and happy.
And technology is just sort of the grand march of progress.
And he basically says, like,
hmm, that's not really how it goes.
And his line is something like,
if this is just another Industrial Revolution
we're living through,
then, like, alarm bells should be ringing.
Like, we should be really freaked out.
Right, yeah, it's terrifying.
But there is a hopeful,
like, I want to make it clear that, like,
this is not a book that's like all doom and gloom
because I don't actually think we are screwed.
And in fact, I think that
we know from history,
and from just looking at our environment,
like what we need to do to survive,
and to be happy and successful.
This is not destiny.
We don't have to end up suffering in the same way
that people have when they've been displaced
throughout history,
because we actually know what to do to prevent that.
Right, and the solution,
the thesis that you lay out in the book is essentially
to make yourself, I don't know, bulletproof,
but to protect yourself against this rising tide.
That solution resides in being the most human
that we can possibly be.
It's about cultivating our inner humanity, which is
a thesis in contradiction to a more conventional narrative,
which is if you want to be competitive in this world
it's all about STEM.
You got to learn how to code.
You have to be computer proficient,
but those, as you point out in the book,
like all of those pursuits are the first to be automated,
and a terrain in which a human is very ill-equipped
to compete with a supercomputer.
Yeah, that's a really perceptive reading.
And I think that's right.
For a long time we've been training people
to effectively be machines.
We've been telling them major in engineering,
learn to code, optimize your life,
like if there's anything that's inefficient,
or suboptimal about your life,
take that out and get as much done as you can.
All this hustle culture we see
is like very much a product of that sort of attitude about
what's valuable in the economy.
And that was true for a long time.
Like you could differentiate yourself through hard work,
and hustle and just pure effort,
but that's like not what's gonna happen.
That's not what's happening right now.
And we're starting to see that the skills
that are actually in demand right now are these kind of
what we would pejoratively call like soft skills.
It's things like communication and empathy,
and leadership and courage,
the things that machines can't do.
You're never gonna be able to out hustle an algorithm.
Like it's just not possible.
They can work 24 hours a day,
and do millions of calculations a second,
and you're just never gonna keep up.
And so the value is going to shift
from the sort of effort-based things
to the kind of emotional and social things.
And in the book,
I talk about three sort of categories of work
that I think are gonna be really resistant to automation.
And I think that's sort of where people should go.
That being surprising, social, and scarce,
which is, basically, your first tenet
in this list of nine things.
Yeah, you got it.
So those are the three types of work
that I think is gonna be hard to automate.
And this was drawn from interviews
with tons of AI executives.
This was not just me sort of sitting in my office
like dreaming up a strategy.
And this is based on a ton of reporting.
And the things that I asked AI experts were basically
what are humans good at that machines right now are bad at?
And they told me that that basically
falls into these three categories,
surprising, social, and scarce.
So let's just take them one at a time.
So surprising is sort of like work that involves kind of
irregular environments, changing rules, lots of variables,
things that aren't predictable or regular.
Look, AI really likes rules,
and bounded environments, and structure.
And so that's why it's really good at playing chess,
for example,
because every game of chess has exactly the same rules,
but if you train an AI to be a kindergarten teacher,
like, it's not gonna do so well, right?
Like, it's gonna be pretty bad at that.
And that's because there's so many environments,
there's so many variables,
there's so much going wrong at any given time.
You have to be really adaptable and flexible to do that job.
And so that's for now that's human work.
Social jobs are jobs that involve making people feel things
rather than making things.
So this is all the sort of compassionate jobs we think of,
social workers, home care workers, ministers, therapists,
people like that,
but it also includes things that you wouldn't think of
as being social jobs, like baristas, for example.
On one level that's a job
that got automated a long time ago.
We have machines in our houses
that make perfectly good coffee,
but we still like to go to, I mean, pre-COVID,
we still like to go to coffee shops
because there's a human element there.
We're getting something out of that transaction
that's more than just a cup of coffee.
So those kinds of jobs are gonna be hard to automate
because machines aren't that good at making us feel things,
and people are much better at that.
And then the final category is scarce jobs,
which is sort of people who have rare skills
are excellent in their fields.
People who are sort of working
in like low fault tolerant environments.
So people like EMTs,
and people who answer the phone when you call 911.
Those jobs are gonna be very hard to automate.
Right, when I think about
you and your career, I see somebody who
created a situation in which you differentiated yourself
from your peers.
Like you, on some level you've created a personal brand
around the kind of beat that you're on,
and the stories that you tell.
And I just know as somebody who follows you,
yes, I have reverence for "The New York Times,"
and that means something,
but I'm not opening up "The New York Times" app
to see what "The New York Times" has to say about subject X.
It's like I want to know what Kevin thinks about this,
or I want to know what Taylor Lorenz thinks about
this other internet thing.
Whether it's Nicholas Kristof, or David Brooks,
or whoever it is,
this idea that you inject your work with your personality.
And that becomes so embedded in what you do
that some AI could cover a subject matter,
but it wouldn't have the imprimatur of what you do.
And so you create career safety for yourself
by carving that out.
Yeah, and I want to be clear,
like, this was not an intentional strategy on my part.
Like, I did not think, like, I am gonna run from the robots
by starting podcasts, and writing newsletters,
and being on Twitter all the time, like,
but I think a lot of us in industries
that have been challenged by automation like journalism
have sort of subconsciously adapted in these ways
that make sense when we look back at them.
So, yeah, I did used to write formulaic stories.
I wrote the most boring corporate earnings reports
you could ever imagine, like,
Alcoa made $7 million in its smelting division last quarter.
Like, that's the kind of stuff
I was doing early in my career.
And then I sort of started realizing, like,
I need to kind of like
put a little bit more of myself into my work
because otherwise I'm replaceable,
not necessarily by an AI, but just by another person.
And so I started infusing more of my personality into stuff,
and I think that's what's happening in the media
writ large right now is you're starting to see the kind of
it's almost like moving from like an industrial economy
to an artisanal economy.
It's sort of like we used to be these factories,
newspapers used to be these factories that churned out,
like, pink slime, essentially.
And like all content was sort of the institutional,
like, voice from God.
And it was like,
it didn't matter really who the by-lines were
'cause that wasn't really what people opened it for.
And now you're starting to see kind of like,
what I call, like, artisanal content making,
which is like I am one person, you are following me.
This is my opinion, this is my reporting.
I'm not gonna hide the fact
that I am a person who made this.
And that's, I think where we're headed,
not just in journalism, but in a lot of industries.
Right, and it plays out not just in individuals,
but in corporations as well.
Like you want to find that cool shop
that's on the main drag of the groovy town
that is not part of
the Pottery Barn, Gap industrial complex, like,
and that's becoming harder and harder to do,
so then we then develop a greater sense of value
around those things.
Yeah, there's a whole chapter about this in the book.
I did a lot of reading around the psychology of value,
and why we value certain things more highly than others.
And there's a concept in social science
called the effort heuristic, and, basically, what it says
is that we attach value to things
that we think people worked really hard on.
So they've run experiments.
There's a professor at UNC who's run all these experiments
where he gives people a bag of candy, and he says,
this candy was randomly selected for you and people eat it.
And they give another group of people
the exact same bag of candy,
but instead of saying this was randomly selected,
they say a human picked this out for you,
specially based on your tastes, and they love it.
Like, it makes a big difference
in their appreciation of the thing
when they think that someone else worked hard on it.
So I think this is a really good roadmap
for like where the economy, and where our jobs are headed
is I think that we have this tendency to want to say, like,
we want to sort of remove ourselves from our work,
and sort of the biggest compliment you could pay someone
for awhile was like, oh, he makes that look so easy,
but I think that's actually not.
Like I think what we're moving to is an economy
in which people who say, oh, he worked so hard on that.
Like that becomes the thing that is valuable.
Everything that is done by machines will become cheap,
and inexpensive and easy,
and everything that's done by humans will be valuable,
and hard and will be rewarded for that hardness.
Right, I don't necessarily want the coffee mug
that I can buy at Target,
but I really want the one that Seth Rogen made in his house
on his pottery wheel.
I love Seth Rogen's pottery, I'm sort of obsessed, yeah.
No, and I think that's like,
so one of the rules in the book,
in the second half of the book is leave handprints
because I think we've gotten accustomed as sort of workers
to kind of trying to, like, make everything we do perfect,
and look effortless,
and, like, take away all traces of the fact
that we struggled over something,
but I think what we should be doing is really emphasizing
the humanity that goes into something,
emphasizing that we are people who are making things,
who are doing labor in the world,
and that that's what makes it valuable,
that we're not machines.
And there's a great talk by this guy, Yann LeCun,
who's the head of AI research at Facebook,
and he uses the example of a flat screen TV,
and a ceramic bowl.
So kind of like your Seth Rogen mug.
And he says flat screen TV
is like an amazing piece of technology.
It's got hundreds of parts,
it's got rare-earth metals, it's got lasers,
and it's entirely made by robots start to finish.
And as a result, like, you can get a pretty good TV
for a couple hundred bucks,
but a ceramic bowl that's made by, like, a talented artisan,
technology that's been around for thousands of years
that's gonna cost you probably more than the flat screen TV.
And the reason for that is not 'cause
it involves more labor, or more technology,
it's 'cause it's done by a human rather than a machine.
And he thinks that's gonna be the wave of the future.
And I sort of agree.
What's really interesting about that
is that we're seeing that sensibility
getting played out in the digital space now with NFTs.
Like isn't an NFT,
a digital version of the one-off piece of pottery?
Totally, I have some questions about NFTs.
I'm actually writing about them right now.
I'd love to know what you think about them.
I mean, I still, I barely understand it at all, so.
You haven't paid 200 grand for a GIF of Michael Jordan?
Yeah, I mean, I think there's something to this idea
of creating scarcity on the internet,
because what enables the artisan
to charge hundreds of dollars for that ceramic bowl
is that there's only one of them, right?
And you can't duplicate it a million times for free.
So I think that's.
You could, sorry to interject, but you could 3D print it,
and create an exact replica of that
in the way that you could copy a JPEG, or a GIF,
but there's still the understanding
that it's not the original.
Right, and there's some friction involved in that.
It's not a simple process, or it's not free and infinite,
the way that copying a file is.
So I think there is value in creating
a model for scarcity on the internet.
I don't know whether NFTs are it.
There's been some reporting on sort of
the environmental questions around NFTs,
and whether we should be burning all this carbon
to like produce these.
I love there was a tweet the other day, it said, like, yes,
I left 11 Ford F-150s idling for 15 hours,
but now the computer says I own a drawing of Spider-Man.
Right.
Which I loved.
I don't understand why
so much carbon has to be burned for these,
but, obviously, there's a reason
that has to do with blockchain,
and stuff that I don't understand.
Right, so, yeah, I'll figure that out.
I'll come back and tell you all about it, but I'm actually,
like, I'm glad that people are working on this
because I think that one aspect,
one precondition for this kind of change in the economy
where we're moving away from mass production,
and toward sort of artisan production,
is that you need to be able to protect scarcity,
and protect artists and get them paid
for doing these kind of specialized works.
And so right now that doesn't really exist on the internet.
So I'm hopeful about NFTs.
Maybe I'm a sucker,
but I feel like it could be good for people, people like us.
Well, I think we're just at the starting gate of something
that I think could fundamentally change how we think about
ownership and creation.
We're seeing it now with JPEGs and pieces of art,
but it doesn't take a huge mental leap to see
how that impacts essentially everything that gets created.
I mean, Kevin, you could write a short story, or a book,
make that an NFT, and do a limited run.
Like, anything that you produce that is of you
can be valued in a way that's very different
than how we think about ownership, and
demand currently.
Yeah, I'm thinking about it.
Should I turn this book into an NFT?
I think you should. I think that would be, well, I mean,
you're the perfect person to do it, right?
It could be like this meta Charlie Kaufmanesque
sort of adaptation experience
of, like, exploring the world of NFTs through
a work, a written work that is itself an NFT.
Yeah, I'll have to talk to Random House.
I'm not sure how copyrights work with NFTs.
Well, I seriously doubt.
I might get a call from the lawyers.
That publishing houses have any concept of this right now.
You don't think they're talking to Malcolm Gladwell about
his next book-length NFT.
I don't know, they should be.
Whether they are or not, who knows?
I mean, I've thought about it.
I'm really intrigued by this.
And I think it could be the answer to something
that artists and creators have been looking for
for a long time because right now the way that artists,
and creators get paid, most of them, on the internet,
is that they put their content into these giant machines
run by algorithms that we call YouTube and Instagram,
and Facebook and Twitter.
The platform sell ads against them.
And then they kick back, sometimes,
some small percentage of what they're making to the creators
who have no control over what that percentage is,
and no control over the algorithm.
And they are basically like serfs,
in the, like, feudal empires
that these platforms have built.
And so I think any model that sort of allows people
to kind of cut out those middlemen is a good one.
And I probably shouldn't say that 'cause I am,
I work for a middleman.
Like, I'm part of the industrial content model here
at "The New York Times."
And I think there's a role for institutions,
and I'm not a burn it all down,
mass media is over, like, I don't think that's true,
but I do think it's good for creators
to have different models of getting paid.
Yeah, 100%, but you do have one thing in the book,
which is arm the rebels.
So there's a little bit of a punk rock aesthetic in here,
rise up against the machines.
Yeah, I mean, it's hard to talk about this stuff
without sounding like I'm saying technology's bad,
and automation's bad, and all this stuff is bad,
and things were better before.
Like, I'm not like nostalgic like that.
Like, I grew up on the internet, I love the internet,
and I want it to be the best version of itself.
And I also think that, like, the way that our internet
is arranged right now is, like, we're not doing so good.
And so I have this in the book I talk about these two people
in the 19th century.
One is Henry David Thoreau who wrote "Walden."
And he was sort of the grouchy like tech-phobe of his day.
He was like, this stuff all sucks.
I'm moving to the woods, and I'm gonna write about
my transcendental life in the woods.
And there was also this other woman very close to him
who is not as well-known, but her name was Sarah Bagley.
And she was a labor organizer.
She actually was one of the people
who worked in the factories in the Industrial Revolution,
and became a labor leader.
And she advocated for, not for she wasn't a Luddite,
she wasn't breaking machines,
but she wanted workers to be treated better.
She wanted the machines to produce
more prosperity for the people who are operating them,
and not just for the owners.
And, ultimately, she became America's
first female telegraph operator, which I love.
Like, she was sort of this groundbreaking person
who was part of this technological revolution.
She took the opposite approach.
She didn't run away from the technology.
She leaned into it and she tried to make it fairer,
and better, and more equitably distributed.
And like, I think that's the model I'm getting behind here.
It's not this stuff sucks,
and we should all throw our phones
in the nearest body of water and go live in the woods.
Like, I think we have to engage with this,
or else it shapes us, and we don't get to shape it.
Right, if you don't engage with it
then you truly do become a throw-esque character.
And it's just not an option for navigating the world.
Especially if you're a young person,
you have to be literate in these tools,
but it becomes incumbent upon you to shoulder
the responsibility of managing your life in such a way
that they're not commandeering your decision-making,
and driving you towards outcomes that you don't want.
So a big part of the book,
in addition to canvasing what the workplace
currently looks like, and quite possibly will look like,
it's about tools for how to manage
your own interior life, right?
You talk about doing these digital detoxes,
and learning how to sort of be in charge of your phone
rather than letting your phone be in charge of you.
So talk a little bit about what that was like
'cause you kind of did that experientially.
Yeah, so I think one hard thing.
So the message of the book is pretty simple it's that
in order to survive this wave of AI and automation,
and keep our jobs, and be happy, and healthy,
and prosperous, and good members of communities,
we need to become more human, pretty simple message.
The hard part about that is there are forces
that are conspiring to make us less human,
and some of those are right on our phone.
And so we interact with them everyday.
Today, before I came on this podcast with you,
like I woke up, I checked my phone,
I saw what was happening on Twitter,
checked my Instagram feed,
asked Alexa what the weather was gonna be like,
listened to a Spotify playlist
that was automatically generated for me.
Like, I am not immune to these forces either.
And all of that is kind of making us less individualized,
and differentiated and making us sort of more homogenous,
and I think less human.
And so one of the things that I tried to do
as part of this book is do this kind of phone detox,
but it was not really about using my phone less.
Like, I think we all use our phones a lot.
I'm not sure, what's your screen time like these days?
I'm embarrassed to admit, I mean, just so many hours,
I mean, with the pandemic it's ramped up,
and it's just embarrassing as somebody who hosts a podcast
about well-being to then get that alert on Sunday
that tells you how much you've been on your phone.
I know, I hate that alert so much for the last year.
I'm trying to disable it, but you can't I don't think.
No, it wants to shame you,
and it wants to tell you how badly you're doing,
but I actually don't think,
like, screen time itself is the problem.
I think the problem is that
we delegate authority to our phones.
If you remember, like, the first phone you got,
it was a tool, right?
Like, you used it to call people.
You might have had texting, like, the T9 texting.
Like, you would use that.
You would use it as a calculator.
You might use it to play "Brick Breaker,"
or "Sneak," or whatever, but it was a tool.
And then over time they became
sort of our bosses in this way.
They tell us what to think about, what to do,
what to care about, what news stories to read,
who to communicate with, how to communicate with them.
They sort of run our lives
in this way that I think is very harmful.
And so my phone detox,
which I actually got a phone coach for,
who guided me through this 30 day process,
like going to rehab for phone addiction.
That might be a futureproof occupation.
Oh, there are gonna be phone coaches
in every town in America like this is gonna be.
I didn't even know that was a thing.
If I were a brazen capitalist, I would open up,
like, the world's largest center for phone rehab.
And I would just have hundreds of thousands of people
streaming into my rehab centers everyday
'cause they can't think for themselves anymore.
So yeah, I think that's part of what I did
to sort of try to futureproof myself was to say, like,
it's not just about using your phone less.
It's not about being distracted.
It's not about being productive.
It's literally about, like, figuring out who you are,
and what you actually value, and separating these categories
of like identification and identity,
because I think our phones and the technology in our lives
want us to blur those things together.
So I try to spend at least an hour everyday
just like no phone around me, I call it human hour.
And I go work in my garden, or I take the dog out,
or I do something that is just my time
to kind of remind myself, like, I am not my digital avatar.
I am not a creature of the internet.
I actually am a person in the offline world who has desires,
and hopes, and beliefs, and values.
And so that's sort of my daily chores to remind myself,
like, I am not who I show up as on the internet.
Yeah, it's super powerful.
I mean, this is something that Cal Newport
has written extensively about.
Everybody should read his book, "Digital Minimalism."
He's got this new book out about a world beyond email.
And I think the kind of mental leap,
or what makes it so challenging,
especially, for somebody like yourself or myself,
who plies their trade online to some degree
there's a feeling, or a fear of irrelevance,
or if you opt out for a minute
that suddenly you're jeopardizing
what it is that you do for a living, and decoupling that,
like, trying to understand that that's actually not true,
and that it is core to the quality of what you do
for a living to put distance between yourself and technology
from time to time, but it's hard.
It's hard, no, I'm not saying it's easy.
Look, I struggle with this everyday.
And my wife will tell you, like, I am not an ideal
phone free meditator.
Well, you have the ultimate, like, excuse.
It's like, this is my beat.
I have to know what's going on in tech.
I have to be on this all the time.
Things are happening quickly.
This is what I'm writing about.
Exactly, if I'm up at one a.m. looking at TikToks,
I mean, that's work, those are billable hours.
No, but I think that's sort of the story I tell myself,
but in reality, like, these are very powerful machines.
Every time you look at your phone,
you are looking at a device
on which hundreds of billions of dollars have been spent
to make you distracted
from whatever else you might have been thinking about.
The world's smartest engineers are working on
how to stop you from looking away from your phone.
And so I think we tell ourselves
that we need to be plugged in,
but, actually, I think there's something happening right now
where, like, I am in awe of people
who are not slaves to their technology.
I mean, sometimes, even when you read a book,
you can just tell like, oh, this person is not on Twitter.
It's almost transgressive
when you see somebody reading a book.
Yeah, and it's like they're more evolved than I am.
Like, they are not in the same.
Like, they are eating artisanal slow food.
And I am over here, like, chowing down on KFC,
and like, we are not the same.
And so I think in the present and in the future
there will be a real value
to being able to separate yourself from your phone,
and your feeds and your technology,
because that's how we get better.
I mean, everything in life that makes us better,
very little of it happens through the phone.
It happens through taking on personal challenges,
through struggling, through raising families,
through building communities.
Like that's the stuff that is really hard,
and really rewarding.
Until we graduate to the ultimate virtual world
where we can just upload our consciousness
into an alternate reality,
and create the utopia of our dreams.
Exactly, I want the "WALL-E" chairs, like I want,
I just want to be driven around by a robot,
and drink my Big Gulp some days.
To your law school class at Walmart.
Exactly, exactly.
If you were giving counsel to a young person now
who's listening to this who's grappling with like,
well, what should I pursue,
or what would be the best way to set myself up
to be futureproof?
What are some of the things other than just the general,
like, double down on the soft skills,
like, where is your head in terms of,
like, where you would direct that person?
Well, there's a chapter in the book called
"Learn machine age humanities."
And I don't think that just studying classics,
or philosophy, or art history is enough.
Like, I don't think that's gonna prepare people,
but I do think there are these skills
that we can teach people that will help them,
no matter what they choose to study.
So one of them is this idea of guarding our attention.
I think that's a really underrated skill.
People who are able to kind of control
what they pay attention to, what they think about.
Whether that's meditation,
whether it's getting off their phones,
whether it's reading books,
I think that's a really important skill.
I think there are other skills that we can teach people,
like the value of rest.
I mean, there's a really counterintuitive thing
that I sort of came across,
which is that a lot of the people I knew
who were the highest ranking people in AI and engineering,
hyper, well-respected, thoughtful people
were actually not working, like, 17 hour days.
They were taking time off.
They were going home to their families.
One of them took naps during the day.
I mean, these are like the kinds of things
that we would think, oh, that person's a slacker.
They're not very productive,
but, actually, that's what allows them to do
the kinds of creative and thoughtful human work
that machines can't replicate.
Yeah, an amazing example of that would be
Yuval Noah Harari,
who goes on these extended silent meditation retreats.
And he credits those experiences,
in addition to his daily,
however many hours he does it every single day,
with his ability to have that kind of
objective perspective on really big issues,
and the clarity that he can instill his writing with.
Yeah, and I'm not as good at meditating as that.
Very few are.
I top out at 10 or 12 minutes on my Calm app, but I try,
and I think that's a really important skill
for people to develop.
And I also think that we're starting to see
that there are classes and curriculums
that are being sort of adapted slowly,
and mostly at sort of high-end elite schools,
but you're starting to see things like there's a course,
I think at Stanford.
I don't know what its actual title is,
but people refer to it as empathy for engineers.
So they basically take people who are computer scientists,
and teach them about people,
teach them how to be emotionally intelligent,
how to read people's emotions, how to talk to people.
It's sort of like remedial people skills
for super high IQ engineers.
And you're starting to see that in more disciplines,
there are medical school classes now
where they don't even talk about medicine.
It's about how to talk to patients.
It's about how to communicate with them empathetically,
and to solve their problems and to hear them out.
There's a venture capitalist, Frank Chen,
who invests in a lot of AI startups,
and the book that he recommends to people who work in AI
is this book called
"Everything I Need To Know I Learned in Kindergarten."
And it's written decades ago by this by minister.
And it's all about kind of like
the basic skills of human existence,
sharing, things that we learn in kindergarten,
and then kind of forget.
And so his big thing is those are the skills of the future.
And I agree.
I think that we all could use a refresher course
on the things that we learn in kindergarten.
Yeah, that's powerful.
I mean, in the most general sense, I suppose,
it's about learning how to live your life
non-reactively and more consciously, right?
To the extent that you can develop an objective sense,
an objectivity around just how much
you're reacting to technology and devices,
and develop the skillsets to kind of transcend that
so that you can have the interior life,
and bring that into not just your work,
but your families and your communities,
that seems to be the antidote.
Yeah, and I think that's gonna be a big part
of how we get out of this.
I mean, especially coming out of the pandemic,
I think we're gonna need
a lot of really intentional work on ourselves
because for the last year we've been experiencing the world
primarily through our screens.
We've sort of conflated who we are on the internet
with who we are offline.
And I think we have a lot of rebuilding to do there
of getting back out in the community,
getting back face-to-face with people
when it's safe to do so,
like figuring out what we actually care about,
and value, and who we are because I think,
and Yuval Noah Harari made this point in one of his books,
like, if the algorithms
know you better than you know yourself,
then the power will transfer to them.
Like, you will no longer be in the driver's seat
of your own life, these algorithms and AIs will,
and that's not a good place to be.
And I think that's something
that I am conscious of everyday,
and trying to sort of swim in the other direction from.
Well, I think that's a good place to kind of round it out.
I love the book.
This was so fun.
This is cool, man.
Well, if you're ever in LA you got to come over,
and do it with me in person.
Yeah, I would love to.
Once I get my second shot, I'll be there.
So you had your first shot.
You're waiting on the second one.
I did, yes, yes.
Cool.
So yeah, next time we'll do it in person.
Right, and maybe a final thought,
I'm interested in how you,
like, today's pub day for your book,
so, obviously, you're going out and you're doing press,
and the way in which authors try to market their books
seems to change, like, almost every year,
in terms of, like, what works and what doesn't,
like the attention graph is such a radically elastic thing,
like it used to be.
It's weird as hell, man.
You wrote about this the other day,
like, you used to just,
if you could just get on, like, the morning talk show,
on the "Today" show, or "Good Morning America,"
and then maybe you get a nice review
in "The New York Times,"
or you're in the Sunday Book section, like, you're cool.
And then it was about the digital space
doing a bunch of podcasts, or doing a Reddit AMA,
which I know you did the other day,
but, like, attention is so fractured now
that it's so difficult
to try to marshal the number of eyeballs
that you would wish to have
when you're sharing your work with the world.
Yeah, and it's fun to experiment with things.
I'm doing, 'cause book tours obviously aren't happening,
so I'm doing a Clubhouse book tour.
Oh, cool.
I'm going around and doing different rooms
with different clubs on Clubhouse
that are talking about some of these issues.
I'm gonna have a virtual book party on Twitter tonight
at Twitter Spaces tonight.
So I'm having fun experimenting.
I'm sure it's very stressful to be a book publicist
in the year 2021, but it's not, I just write the books.
It's somebody else's job to sell them.
Uh-huh, no, that's not true, that's where you're wrong.
It's your job, the fact that you have to understand that,
like shoulder that responsibility, my friend.
All right, I'm convinced.
All right, cool.
Well, this was super fun.
I appreciate the work that you do.
I always look forward to every new piece that you write.
I love following you online.
So congrats on the new book, it's called,
"Futureproof: 9 Rules for Humans in the Age of Automation."
Kevin's easy to find on the internet @kevinroose on Twitter,
and all the places.
Anywhere else you want to direct people?
You've got this new newsletter now.
Yeah, I got a new newsletter called "Futureproof" also.
It's at futureproof.tips, T-I-P-S.
I'll be sending out one newsletter a week
on sort of the issues in the book,
and how you can be more human.
Cool, all right, man.
Come and talk to me again sometime.
Thanks so much.
All right, peace.
All right, take care.